it's been an amazing 24 hours even by
the action-packed standards of 2018
there's been a lot of drama in
Washington last night as you doubtless
know former New York City Mayor Rudy
Giuliani revealed on Sean Hannity's show
that President Trump did in fact
reimburse his lawyer Michael Cohen for
payments Cohen made two porn star store
McDaniels that seemed like a major story
at the time but within hours it wasn't
even the biggest story of the day NBC
News reported that federal law
enforcement had wiretap Michael Cohen's
phone and apparently recorded at least
one conversation he'd had with the White
House presumably with the President of
the United States but then that story
changed NBC's new account claims that
the FBI simply recorded the numbers that
Cohen dialed and not the content of the
calls he made and that's where we are as
of right now 8:00 p.m. Eastern Time one
thing we know for sure is that NBC
screwed up and there's no surprise there
obviously but that's pretty much all we
can be certain of if NBC's first story
was wrong why do we assume the second is
right we really don't know what the
truth is and we have no way of knowing
in the absence of honesty from our
government we're totally dependent upon
leaks for our news and many of those are
dishonest Michael Cohen by the way still
doesn't know why his office was raided
and his phones and email were apparently
monitored by the government because
nobody in government will tell him and
they're not required to tell him how are
well ian is that by the way imagine if
it happened to you if one day our men
arrived to your office or your home and
seized your phone your computers and
your files at gunpoint but never
explained why they were doing it and the
next thing you knew cable news anchors
were calling you a criminal
now Michael Cohen certainly looks like a
shady character but so what
shadiness is not a crime the FBI can't
destroy your life just because you talk
like a character from The Sopranos or
because you work for Donald Trump those
are not felonies basic norms were
violated here attorney-client privilege
is an ancient and a vital concept and by
the way so is privacy
the FBI bulldozed all of that let's hope
they had a very good reason for doing it
the government better have evidence that
Michael Cohen was doing something awful
putting lives at stake or betraying his
country or something really beyond the
pale in order to justify this if it
turns out that all of this was just
about a financial sediment
some porn star which by the way is a
story that not a single American is
honestly shocked by or threatened by no
matter what Anderson Cooper tells you if
that's all it's about
then what we're watching is a grotesque
violation of civil liberties and that
would be a real crime one with actual
victims every American who believed in
representative democracy for example
James Kallstrom is a former assistant
director of the FBI
he joins this time mr. Kallstrom you
spent your life at the FBI
we're very obviously famous leader at
the FBI when you watch the last years
you've watched it unfold how do you
think the bureau's doing well the
leadership of the bureau and the
leadership of the apartment I'm doing
well at all
Tucker I mean it's just outrageous you
know I look back at some records and
during the SNL's in the 80s and 90s you
remember that you know yes literally
thousands of SNL's that they went
belly-up and a lot of corruption a lot
of a criminality not one law firm in the
United States not one law firm was ever
served with a search warrant for that
whole period of time and yet this little
four person or five person law firm that
just happens to be the laws the law firm
of the president United States is
attacked by pen registers by
surveillance by search warrants and you
know to get a search warrant from a
federal judge in the criminal side you
have to you have to talk about a
criminal act that's that's taking place
a criminal predicate and on the national
security side for the FISA judge you
have to talk about the threat to
national security and and talk about you
know why it's going to be affected it
negatively in both cases without these
extraordinary measures I think it's far
fetched I'll be I'll be corrected if I'm
wrong but to see what kind of a
predicate they could have possibly had
in this case well so if it turns out
that this really is all about a payment
to a porn star and I hate to say it but
let's be honest it's just not a
surprising story nobody voting in 2016
is going to be surprised by this if it
turns out that's really the predicate
for this then yeah
things that and nor is it surprising
that Bob Muller would do something like
this it's Bob what listen well I mean
look at the history look at how we
wanted to Paul manifolds house and had
four o'clock in the morning here so
here's a potential if by worse cases a
white-collar crime stuff and you go into
a house at four or five in the morning
with the with weapons shown you drag a
woman out of bed in her nightgown and
the children or I assume screaming
yelling around the house I mean that's
just an outrage we don't operate like
that in the United States if I was a
head of the FBI I would I would have not
let the agents participate now this is
something that came from Mulla up to the
US attorney in New York and they
apparently put together an affidavit and
I guess the FBI was involved with that
and that was presented to a federal
judge and when you go into a lawyer's
office you're going to be really careful
in the way it works today you have
really two teams of people one team goes
in and does the search another team kind
of looks through the material to try to
segment out anything that would it be
privileged and in this case the federal
judge who now has control over this case
has gone a step further and is turning
all that material over to a senior
federal judge Barbara Jones who's a
fantastic judge a good friend of mine
over the years and she'll decide you
know what the US government gets to see
and what the US government doesn't get
to see right but you think and I should
just clear it up for audience we weren't
familiar with your career I wouldn't
describe you as a soft on crime liberal
at all but you think based on decades at
the FBI that what you're watching now is
out of line there's no precedent for it
Tucker I don't believe in kicking in
doors unless there's a reason for it and
I don't believe having outrageous search
warrants you know unless there's a real
bona fide reason is there a criminal
predicate for this I'd be surprised if
there was if it is it's probably some
concoction from some you know stupid
intelligence content
or is it a national-security predicate I
find that would be preposterous you know
I just think these people out of control
from the very time that Donald Trump was
the nominee of the Republican Party
there has been a conspiracy a Fifth
Column call it what you want that has
tried to stop him from getting elected
and number two stop his effective work
for the people of this country and look
at the magnificent job he's done in the
in economic front in the Foreign
Relations front in a year and a half in
my view more than the last three
presidents combined I I'm just I'm
awestruck that you're saying this
because you're not a cable news talking
head and any of our viewers are not
familiar with your career ought to go to
Google and look it up you speak with
authority on this subject and so I'm I'm
I'm shocked by what she said and
saddened but I believe you because you
are believable on this subject mr.
Kallstrom thank you for joining us
tonight